once again another story from the post
millennial Joe Rogan and Elon Musk call
out MSNBC for suggesting being healthy
and in shape is far right
I love it uh is what winning looks like
okay we've had a whole bunch of culture
War Victory segments today
Joe Rogan Tweets in response to MSNBC
who said the far rights obsession with
Fitness is going digital he said being
healthy is quote far right holy f
Patrick Bet David with the best response
says does that hold the inverse being
true that the the left's obsession with
being fat is going digital
but but this isn't uh uh so this is
really funny because if you guys know
the krasensteins are uh we've had them
on the show they're liberal pundits
Brian Craig I think it was Brian he
posted a video of himself working out
and uh looking pretty fit you know good
for him I miss the far right pipeline
but that's what I said I said careful
Brian you keep it up you're gonna become
far right and a bunch of leftists and
liberals started attacking me for it and
I was like dude I'm kidding like I was
I'm joking I I interrupted the guy
positively on on Twitter I recently
shouted him out he said let's not fight
let's like you know he said not
everybody's crazy and extreme you know
we just we just see the world that
family I respect it and I was like you
know all joking aside keep it up bro
looking good and uh the funny thing now
is even he responded to this being like
what like being in shape is far right
and I'm like I warned you like I told
you dude they will call you right wing
if you're into fitness that's how
psychotic the cult is Yo they legit want
you unhealthy unhappy eating bugs and
living in a pod yeah I can understand if
people are getting in shape because they
feel like they're gonna get attacked
that it might be like a form of like a
result of being radicalized like I'm so
afraid for my life now I've gotta defend
myself but if you just want to get
healthy and muscular so you can carry
your kids around I mean come on but
isn't this like the left all the time
they're saying you're gonna misgender me
you're going to do you're gonna have
microaggressions for me like wouldn't
that mean that they should be the ones
getting in shape to defend themselves so
check it out here's the tweet that
everyone's responding to posted July
10th 2023 right here's the story written
March 22nd 2022.
MSNBC knows that they are sparking
controversy have you guys ever seen
those videos there's a couple like a
woman will have a counter and she'll
she'll go like okay here's what we're
gonna do and then she'll take a bag like
an industrial bag of nacho cheese and
just dump it on the counter and then
she'll take a bunch of chips and pour
all over the cheese and then start
mixing it with their hands and you're
like what is she doing like hey watch it
you know exactly they're not real tips I
watched one where it's like she pours
like uh like vinegar into a pan then
pours cream and puts an egg in the
middle and she's like trust me and I'm
like no it's intended to trick you into
watching for a long time so they make
money that's what MSNBC is doing that's
what the left cult is well and in
particular it's sparking it on Twitter
MSNBC knows that people it's it's uh the
algorithm will respond to its tweet
getting a lot of Engagement and
engagement doesn't have to be positive
it doesn't have to be a bunch of people
saying well we love great story good
good reporting people arguing in the
comments makes it look like a lot of
people are interacting with the post
which technically they are although they
are screaming at one another uh that's
the same thing with these food videos
where it's like what is she doing is
this a joke all of the debate makes the
video seem popular to the algorithm
I I'm still taking it back that this is
a year old story that they oh bro
sending viral right now Arnold Arnold is
Jim Denny says Fitness is not political
right or left all of us can benefit from
the lessons of progressive resistance
training creating a vision goal building
a routine doing the Reps learning to
love failure the list goes on if you
don't know where to start Arnold's pump
Club see I can respect everybody's
basically being like dude Bridget
fantasy says the only way to prove
you're not a Nazi is to get fat
apparently it's the only way look at
this it's amazing these are all the
responses of everyone just mocking MSNBC
yeah here's Abby Libby on Twitter saying
someone please inform MSNBC I'm about to
do a little far right extremism diving
into the lap pool to go exercise we
should just call exercising Far Right
Far Right extremism or club owner we're
gonna go engage in some foreign
extremism at the gym tomorrow then
they'll probably strike down gym classes
from schools because after all the years
of being like kids need exercise they'll
be like we can't indoctrinate children
to be conservative this is I there's got
to be more to this story Maybe here's
more of the story News Guard rates
msnbc.com 57 out of 100 proceed with
caution this website generally fails to
maintain basic standards of accuracy and
accountability wow wow Pence tweeting
out of your old story they're like we
don't care that's the old guard man they
just News Guard fact check newsguard
yeah anything possible I don't know yeah
I mean
here's uh Fox News 69.5 out of 100. Fox
News has more credibility according to
News Guard than MSNBC does oh I can hear
everyone's liberal Aunt screeching and
saying that's not true News Guard is far
right
okay lady no lady go back to the gym go
back to the gym and they don't go are
you trying to convert her are you trying
to indoctrine I'm a Pilates fan so but
but I do think that there is there's an
obvious correlation between working out
being fit and being conservative yeah I
think so too you're going to like two
things one someone who's willing to work
out clearly sees the benefits of hard
work for long-term uh gains over
short-term gains a short term you're
gonna be tired I think working out
really does feel fantastic though but
long term you feel like you know a ball
to lightning you feel fantastic
somebody who feels that way probably
already understands a lot of basic
conservative Concepts but then there's
also the correlation between
testosterone you know aggression and
being more conservative you're going to
be more assertive you're going to be
more confident you're gonna feel better
at yourself working out will likely have
you end up being more quote unquote far
right but if this were true just like
every Nazi would be would be jacked and
like the reality is whenever you see
like actual people waving Nazi Flags
they're like very heavy or very gaunt
and frail looking like not very healthy
looking individuals that's the weirdest
thing too it's like why are why did
MSNBC try to make this argument in the
first place are they trying to convince
look at look at this picture can we just
look at it's a it's okay it's a bunch of
Nazis doing the robin salute and then
there's a guy a flexing arm what's the
black they're covering up oh I don't
know trying to cut like because it's
artsy yeah sure edgy hyper masculinity
I've always been Central to the far
right what how are these people
simultaneously arguing that
conservatives are like chuds but also
that they're super jacked and ripped
hyper masculinity was a big part of
Mussolini's fascist thing you wanted to
make the the Italian river uh masculine
so he changed the gender of the word of
the name and he was big on like the
father land and stuff like that but that
doesn't mean that
uh working out in general makes you a
fascist or just because he was masculine
yeah or what if masculinity includes uh
taking responsibility thinking long term
like those don't have to be negative
qualities no matter what major media
thinks right there can be positive
qualities of masculinity that result in
someone wanting to make sure they
maintain a high level of uh physical
strength and health like they have just
decided these things are bad and they
want to use the phrases that make you
scared of them right that's why they put
an image of you know Nazis on screen to
be like you don't want to be hyper
masculine that's bad hyper mass is so
like what masculinity is like I guess
you get too much testosterone you stop
feeling is that the problem with
masculinity you lose touch with your
emotions because you're in touch with
like what you grab in front of you
um but is there any indication of that I
don't know I feel like that's super true
uh I don't know what is your experience
with testosterone have you gone through
T levels high testosterone low
testosterone in your life well I'm bald
so apparently that means I have a lot of
testosterone I have a lot I don't know
you're pretty driven I I exercise a lot
uh I skate a lot and I eat a lot of beef
I didn't used to eat a lot of beef
that's the only reason I've been eating
cheeseburgers like non-stop for summer I
can't I don't ask me why it's like Smash
Burgers just you're gonna say Burgers
far right extremism yeah no but
typically would eat a lot of chicken and
fish most of my life and uh actually
don't like eating a lot of beef because
I usually we get sick actually I was
getting pretty sick so we I too much oh
man you know for dinner we made Smash
Burgers
but we fried them in bacon grease
and I'm like it's the most delicious
thing I've ever had and then I was like
oh where's it on my girls so maybe I
should do that again your arteries
anyway I know what my point is uh
I've been exercising I've been skating
literally my whole life so there's two
things that come with this
um skateboarding is is I guess
considered a high risk high impact sport
jumping off buildings jumping downstairs
it's an adrenaline rush Non-Stop
it's not like active conflict or
anything but I but a lot of people told
me it's unsurprising that I got involved
in urban conflict reporting stuff
because when you're skateboarding you're
looking at something that's terrifying
and dangerous and you're going for it
every time and it's giving you that that
adrenaline rush so you are desensitized
to that shock and then you're like oh I
can go and handle this I'm not going to
get hurt well but but the physical
ability the physical activity of it you
know I would be uh in you know just
before Occupy Wall Street for instance I
would skate eight hours a day every
single day with like one or two days off
per week and so I would man I I was
consuming thousands of calories per day
like insane amounts of calories to try
and keep up and if I didn't I would pass
out like some days I would just eat a
couple thousand calories and I would
just be like I'll just chill today and
maybe skate tomorrow because I can't do
it and then there will be days where I
was just like I was shedding weight
really really like this period where I
was in Virginia I was in Newport News
and I was skating at a park called
anti-gravity I was skating so often I
lost like 10 pounds in a couple weeks
just like and uh but that that exercise
builds muscle
increases your testosterone levels
you're going to be a certain kind of
person yeah also probably when you got
into
or like I how old you were but like
you probably okay so you're
always going through Purity have
obviously an increase in testosterone
and it's linked to an increase in
risk-taking Behavior so when your brain
was forming you learned how to take
calculated risks physically uh I don't
think these things these traits of
masculinity and testosterone don't have
to be negative yeah I think that they're
conflating misogyny with masculinity
because I think that's on purpose though
yeah it could be because like the Andrew
Tate stuff he said some stuff that was
misogynist I I think let's let's yeah
like he's gonna get some guys trick them
get fake women to guys that pretend like
they're women to chat with dudes to get
their money like using women as like an
object that's a bit misogynist but the
man he's also very masculine like he's
he works out he eats healthy he's about
motivation so you've got to strip away
the misogynist crap from the hyper
masculine stuff or the masculine stuff
and I working out is definitely more of
a masculine trait not I has nothing
about it is misogynistic in my opinion
no I don't think it has to be thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time